hello reject nation
Greg Alva here and I am a Jake Pollard's
Dalton is your leader I just showed
Anita the official trailer for it and I
had a camera rolling didn't realize
you'd get so freaked I'm a little bit
traumatized like freaking out now and
it's like I literally just watched it so
I don't have that I shouldn't turn the
mission recorded I'm stupid from doing
that you Gregory I've got like this
beard is definitely not the it I
remember I've had a lot of requests to
check out just the TV spots okay
only a few only 30 seconds long okay but
if people are like it's just a TV spot
but I'm telling you it's worth it okay
all right thank your word for it
[Music]
how many symbols CDs so creepy that last
moment he's not the same clown I
remember the cute little Tim Curry okay
she wasn't cute but it was kind of kind
of hiya Julie yeah is that what that is
not the same one you thought more of the
creepy sensitive type of clay no that's
sounds like a child worry Mikey Pletcher
the thing to deal with
yeah yes this one gets a lot more under
your skin when I rewatched the other one
it was like he talks so much and he's so
like out there at the time yeah I agree
that he's certainly incredibly
entertaining but the fear factor of him
definitely yeah I mean unless you're
like a kid and then clowns or they look
like that they're creepy they're gonna
scare you but if you're an adult it's
not really going to be that bad this guy
here is freaking scary that was like
that actually gave me a little bit of
fear and I don't have an irrational fear
of clowns not that it's irrational yeah
do you have it but I don't and that will
probably destroy my psyche I think it's
great to change up the demeanor and the
voice yeah that's a degree if you've
seen it you're not going to forget how
that clown came across no you're not and
this one it's a totally different type
of take and it's the only way to make it
satisfied khana can't just redo what tim
curry did it's based off of a book so if
you do the exact same interpretation as
Tim Curry's if you're not providing
anything unique one you could just go to
the book and then try to find something
different than what Tim Curry did and if
you want to watch the Tim Curry version
you can always use your watch listen
guys there's no there's no reason to
reboot it and make it exactly the thing
and I felt like the first one was so
campy and cheesy and I'm like this one
looks like I'll take it very serious on
them in the theatre six I'm excited for
it look side forward - I'm definitely
going to check it out I'm probably going
to need a lot of arms around me to grab
in tension I have long like the ones
coming out of that door
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell don't worry both
buttons don't do much just do it anyone
need a star the Anita star channel or
need a stargazer be coming there to
becoming gaze at night okay tonight
that's the word and yeah patreon exists
it's a great website go to its patron
comm check it I mean is an amazing
website that's a lotta doesn't check out
the real rejects I mean anyone have to
subscribe at this point at this point Oh
sketching other pages you decide to fly
cater okay yeah